voilà
je propose que que nous commencions
bonjour à tous mais mes chers collègues
madame la rapporteur nous poursuivons
cet après-midi nos travaux de notre
commission d'enquête sur la pénurie de
médicaments et les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique françaises notamment
materinovation puisque la question des
pénuries est liées à cette déco
également autant que de la disponibilité
par l'audition donc de Monsieur Thomas
fantôme qui est le directeur général de
la Caisse nationale de l'assurance
maladie
accompagné madame Julie pou alors poujon
directrice de l'offre de soins de la
CNAM donc je vous remercie monsieur le
directeur général Madame la Directrice
de votre présence parmi nous aujourd'hui
comptant plus de 2500 salariés la CNAM
est chargé de la gestion de la branche
maladie comme de la branche accident du
travail et maladie professionnelle dans
ce cadre elle a notamment pour fonction
de veiller à l'équilibre financier des
branches et participe en application du
code de la sécurité sociale au comité
économique des produits de santé que
nous avons déjà auditionné et qui a
témoigné donc de votre présence active
au sein de ce comité donc chargé des
laboration de la politique économique et
de la fixation des prix des médicaments
qui ont nécessairement un impact sur
l'équilibre budgétaire de la CNAM
au-delà des questions financières la
CNAM joue un rôle majeur dans
l'organisation et la transformation du
système de santé
elle promeut des actions de prévention
d'éducation et d'information de nature à
améliorer l'état de santé des assurés
mettant oeuvre les accords
conventionnels
d'actualité conclut avec les
professionnels de santé et développent
la maîtrise médicalisée des dépenses
comme les autres têtes de réseau elle
conclut avec l'État une convention
d'objectifs et de gestion déterminant
les objectifs pluriannuels de
l'Assurance Maladie pour la période
2018-2022 la convention invite notamment
la CNAM à renforcer la qualité et la
pertinence des parcours de soins en
veillant à développer le recours aux
médicaments génériques et bios similaire
comme approuvé promouvoir la pertinence
des prescriptions
aussi la CNAM joue-t-elle un rôle clé
dans la régulation des dépenses de
médicaments comme dans la promotion des
bonnes pratiques de prescription
c'est la raison pour laquelle il nous a
semblé indispensable de vous entendre
dans le cas de cette commission
d'enquête alors que le nombre de
médicaments connaissant des ruptures ou
des tensions d'approvisionnement ne
cesse d'augmenter
pour mémoire était 2018 premier rapport
du Sénat sur la pénurie mission flash
nous étions aux alentours de 700
médicaments pénurie nous atteignons
quasiment les 3000 actuellement alors
avec voilà d'une semaine à l'autre ça
change et d'un territoire à l'autre et
nous souhaiterions que vous puissiez
présenter dans un bref propos
introductive votre analyse de la
situation actuelle sur ce sujet dans
quelle mesure et de quelle manière la
CNAM cherche-t-elle dans le cadre de ses
missions à prévenir les difficultés
d'approvisionnement en médicaments
dispose-t-elle de données précises sur
le coût financier des ruptures et leurs
implications sanitaires qui ont
également un coût financier puisque ça
peut se traduire par une moindre une
prise en charge sanitaire voire des des
retards de prise en charge comment
promet-elle auprès des professionnels de
santé là la pertinence des prescriptions
je passerai ensuite la parole à Laurence
Cohen qui est rapporteur de notre
commission d'enquête et je précise que
cette audition est diffusée en direct
sur les sites internet du Sénat et
qu'elle fera l'objet d'un compte rendu
publié avant de vous passer la parole
Monsieur le Directeur Général Madame la
Directrice je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles
34343 14 400
excusez-moi à force de les dire je l'ai
dit mal
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal et
je vous invite à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure Monsieur le Directeur Général
madame
je vous remercie vous avez la parole
mesdames et messieurs merci de me donner
la parole je vais rapidement rappeler le
rôle de l'assurance maladie dans le la
politique du médicament et pour venir
ensuite sur le sujet pénurie et évoqué
notre action sur ce sujet spécifiquement
et notamment développer tout ce qui
tourne autour du bon usage du médicament
très rapidement parce que je crois que
c'est des choses que vous avez déjà
évidemment entendu des différents
acteurs rappeler le rôle central de
l'Assurance Maladie donc financeur nous
finançons dans notre pays près de 90%
des dépenses de médicaments si on
regarde ville hôpital donc c'est d'abord
évidemment ce rôle primordial que de j'y
reviendrai garantir l'accès aux soins
des patients par cette prise en charge
publique à ce titre là
on peut résumer les choses en se disant
que nous avons trois
trois rôles d'une part vous l'avez
évoqué également nous sommes membres du
comité économique des produits santé
nous sommes donc parti prenante de cet
instance collégiale à laquelle
d'ailleurs l'assurance maladie est très
attachée instance originale qui assure
la négociation de prix avec les
industriels nous fixons les taux de
remboursement on le sait pas forcément
toujours très très bien mais c'est
l'assurance maladie qui fixe les taux en
réalité elle a peu de marge manœuvre
voire pas de marge manœuvre puisque
cette eau sont fixés dans un corridor
réglementaire et sur la base
d'évaluation de la Haute Autorité de
santé nous nous sommes quelque part en
compétence liées mais ce qui est
relativement normale et puis évidemment
j'y reviendrai de façon plus approfondie
nous jouons un rôle sur le bon usage du
médicament le bon usage des produits de
santé dans le cadre de cette mission
transversale qui nous est confiée
d'assurer l'efficience du système de
soins et de jouer un rôle sur la
pertinence et la qualité des soins
de ce point de vue là si je resserre un
tout petit peu la je dirais la focale
progressivement
s'agissant du médicament l'assurance
maladie a trois priorités en lien avec
les orientations fixées par le Conseil
de la CNAM et également dans le cadre
des relations avec l'État dans le cas de
sa convention d'objectif et de gestion
si je devais trois priorités elles sont
assez simples la première c'est
d'assurer dans les meilleures conditions
possibles un accès des patients des
assurés aux médicaments quand on pose
cela on pense souvent à l'innovation en
terme de d'accès d'animation la période
récente et le thème de votre commission
de votre commission d'enquête le pose
bien
l'actualité nous a montré que ça n'était
pas sûr seulement qu'un sujet
d'innovation mais c'est aussi un sujet
d'accès à des produits plus matures
comme on dit mais en tous les cas être
parti prenante et être un acteur des
conditions qui permettent aux assurés de
notre pays d'avoir un accès à l'ensemble
des produits santé dont ils ont besoin
c'est la première sécurité la deuxième
priorité c'est d'être un acteur de
politique de santé publique autour de
bon usage des produits de santé il est
évident que ces produits de santé
participent de la de la prise en charge
de la qualité des soins et de et de la
guérison de nos assurés je dirais mais
évidemment dans le cadre de référentiel
de santé publique que nous ne
définissons pas c'est la Haute Autorité
de Santé la NSM notamment qui définit
les référentiels mais notre rôle est de
les diffuser et d'assurer leur respect
et donc de participer à cette politique
de santé publique qui est un bon usage
du médicament au service de la santé des
patients troisième
priorité c'est celle de la soutenabilité
de s'assurer que les dépenses de
médicaments obéissent à une logique
déficience et participe plus globalement
à toutes les actions que nous menons
pour essayer de garantir la
soutenabilité de notre modèle
d'assurance maladie et de veiller à ce
que nous appelons la gestion du risque à
déployer des actions de gestion du
risque maladie c'est-à-dire le juste
soin au juste coût
pour nos patients de ce point de vue là
évidemment les la problématique des
pénuries est un sujet important pour
nous parce qu'elle a elle peut être
synonyme de défaillance dans l'accès aux
soins des patients en tout cas de
complications de complexité dans ce
parcours de soins que vous avez évoqué
de ce point de vue là et je ne serais
pas forcément très long parce que je
crois que d'autres acteurs à la fois
sont plus compétents plus experts que
nous et que vous avez déjà auditionné
mais rappelez que ce phénomène est
à la fois tout de même n'est pas récent
puisque ça fait maintenant plusieurs
années que nous faisons face dans notre
pays à des à des pénuries même si c'est
vrai que les chiffres partagés de façon
transparente par les différentes
autorisations sanitaires montrent que ce
phénomène a tendance à s'aggraver c'est
dernières années phénomène qui n'est pas
récent qui s'aggrave phénomène qui est
aussi
multi factorielle là aussi je crois que
c'est des choses qui sont aujourd'hui
assez bien partagées ce qui évidemment
complique la situation dès lors qu'on
essaye d'identifier les les solutions
puisque
on a en face de nous des causes liées à
la fois à des à l'organisation de la
production de différents laboratoires à
des choix d'investissement à des chocs
ou à des aléas conjoncturels avec ce
qu'on a pu connaître pendant le covid et
après le covid à des difficultés
potentielles d'accès aux matières
premières et donc on voit bien que ces
problématiques sont
complexes et ont différentes
explications
de ce point de vue
il nous semble du côté de l'assurance
maladie que si dans ces facteurs
explicatifs il peut y avoir le sujet de
la fixation des prix cela ne nous semble
pas être le principal motif qui explique
la situation de pénurie si vous regardez
la situation d'un pays comme les
États-Unis qui est de loin le pays qui
allait pris les plus élevés ils ne sont
pas loin de là à l'abri de pénurie si
vous regardez en France la situation de
différentes molécules vous verrez que il
peut y avoir
situation et pour prendre un exemple qui
évidemment a été très regardé ces
derniers semaines s'agissant de
notamment l'almoxicilline qui a fait
l'objet de pénurie importante c'est un
sujet où quand on se compare aux autres
pays européens nous ne sommes pas en
France avec les prix les plus bas loin
de la et encore faut-il rappeler la
grande prudence qui s'attache à la
comparaison des prix entre les
différents pays européens puisque la
transparence sur ces sujets est limitée
nous n'avons pas accès en tout cas
l'assurance maladie à la réalité des
prix net effectivement
supporté infinés par les différents
financeurs des systèmes de santé des
différents pays européens
ce qui est de ce point de vue là une
limite aux éléments de comparaison
s'agissant de notre responsabilité je
dirais de nos actions que nous pouvons
mener nous sommes évidemment partie
prenante en tant que membre du Comité
économique et en tant que principal
financeur de tous les travaux que que
les ministres de la Santé et de
notamment de l'industrie porte sur la
lutte contre les pénuries et compris du
de la feuille de route qui se consolide
en soi-même
sous leur sous leur autorité donc nous
participons à l'ensemble des travaux
techniques sur ces différents sujets
peut-être faire un focus plus
significatif sur le rôle qui nous
incombe en matière de bon usage du
médicament je l'ai évoqué
cette
une politique publique très importante
que nous menons et qui quelque part
vise à activer l'ensemble des leviers à
notre disposition qui s'agisse de
l'information des assurés ou des
professionnels de santé qui s'agissent
de l'accompagnement des assurés de
président de santé des incitations
financières de la mise sous-accord
préalable de la lutte contre les trafics
nous mobilisons
ensemble des leviers qui visent à
promouvoir le bon usage des médicaments
et si je prends par exemple des exemples
précis de différents types d'actions sur
l'année 2022 nous avons par exemple
mener près de 7000 visites des délégués
de l'assurance maladie auprès des
médecins généralistes sur le bon usage
du paracétamol sujet au combien
important en matière de de tension de
pénurie ces dernières ces dernières
semaines c'est une action que nous
avions dans nos tiroirs si j'ose dire en
tout cas qui était prête que nous avions
décalé à cause du covid puisque les
portages d'un message sur la modération
de prescription de paracétamol était un
peu compliqué en pleine épidémie de
covid donc nous avons visité près de
7000 médecins généralistes pour leur
rappeler le bon usage du paracétamol et
nous aurons à la fin du premier
trimestre des premiers éléments de bilan
sur cette campagne ce type de démarche
on le on le met en œuvre sur beaucoup
d'autres molécules
15.000 médecins visités par exemple dans
le cadre d'échanges confraternelle par
les médecins conseils et les délégués de
l'assurance maladie sur la metformine
des visites sur les IPP près de 11400
visites également en 2022 sur les
médecins généralistes
et je reviendrai sur d'autres donc une
logique de d'information et
d'accompagnement individualisé auprès
des prescripteurs pour pouvoir
assurer un meilleur respect des
référentiels je le disais autant on peut
on peut dire que sur certaines molécules
les prix ne sont pas la principale
explication il est clair que notre pays
connaît encore sur un certain nombre de
molécules des niveaux de prescription
qui sont notoirement plus élevés que nos
pays européens comparables et c'est le
cas des deux classes qui ont fait
l'objet de pénuru les plus importantes
ces dernières semaines à la fois la
moticilline et le paracétamol où nous
sommes à des niveaux de prescription et
de consommation encore malgré nos
efforts plus élevé que ce que nous
voyons chez nos voisins ce qui
évidemment n'est pas la réponse à la
pénurie mais si on avait moins de
consommation et prescription inadéquate
on aura quand même on serait moins
exposés au risque de pénurie cette
démarche-là elle ne concerne pas
seulement les médecins puisque je
l'évoquais le concerne les patients elle
concerne aussi les autres professions de
santé notamment les pharmaciens et
notamment autour des sujets de lutte
contre l'antibio-résistance et de bons
usages des antibiotiques nous avons
déployé nous continuons à déployer en ce
moment même la valorisation notamment
des trodes sur les angines qui permet
d'impliquer médecin et pharmaciens sur
la vérification de la l'utilité de des
antibiotiques nous avons déployé un
nouveau protocole qui permet de sur le
dépistage urinaire également de
mobiliser les les pharmaciens sur des
tests qui permet aussi de diminuer la
mauvaise utilisation des antibiotiques
nous avons engagé avec eux même s'ils
sont pas totalement enthous iastes la
délivrance la dispense l'unité des
antibiotiques qui permet aussi d'éviter
le gaspillage et la mauvaise utilisation
des antibiotiques et pour citer
également d'autres professions de santé
nous travaillons également nous avons
commencé à travailler avec les
chirurgiens dentistes qui sont également
des prescripteurs
d'antibiothérapie pour essayer de mieux
faire respecter les référentiels
je lisais différents professions de
santé différents mécanismes nous
travaillons aussi nous déployons des
différents mécanismes d'accompagnement
et d'incitation financiers l'exemple le
plus connu c'est évidemment la
rémunération sur objective de santé
publique pour lequel nous sommes
évidemment à votre disposition pour
partager des éléments de bilan sur les
différents indicateurs de la de la Rose
qui porte un certain nombre d'objectifs
sur là aussi
l'antibio-thérapie le bon usage des
médicaments la prescription dans le
répertoire la lutte contre la lettre
génie médicamenteuse y compris sur les
médicaments
anxiolytiques ou psychotropes qui
participent là aussi de de bon usage du
médicament on a des résultats qui sont
différents selon les classes mais qui
dans un certain nombre de situations
témoignent d'un rôle efficace de la rose
sur l'évolution des pratiques des
médecins toujours dans l'accompagnement
financier nous allons un peu plus loin
que la rose en pratiquant une vraie
logique d'intéressement des médecins
au respect des référentiels ou à la
pertinence et à l'efficience des
prescriptions c'est ce que nous avons
déployé depuis 2022 avec
l'intéressement sur la prescription de
BIOS similaire dans le cadre de
l'avenant numéro 9 signé avec les
médecins en juillet
2021 là aussi première année en 2022 on
fera le bilan en premier trimestre 2023
et nous avions proposé de poursuivre
cette démarche dans la négociation
conventionnelle qui n'a pas abouti
autour de la juste prescription des IPP
avec là aussi un intéressement au
respect des des
référentiels avec un partage des gains
pour dire des choses un peu crûment
entre les médecins et l'assurance
maladie toujours dans les leviers qui
sont à notre disposition dans le cadre
du bon usage du médicament cité deux
évolutions
importante dans les outils que nous
déployons peut-être les avez-vous déjà
croisé nos délégués de l'Assurance
Maladie porte depuis plusieurs années
des profils de prescription papier qui
le viennent déposer chez le médecin et
dialoguer avec eux sur leur prescription
et les différences avec leurs collègues
au niveau départemental et national nous
sommes en train de moderniser cette
démarche-là pour utiliser un terme à la
mode de le passer sous un mode de Data
visualisation c'est à dire de mettre à
disposition sous format numérique et
digital c'est donner qui permettent
rafraîchissement plus plus fréquent plus
rapide plus efficace et donc ça c'est
une campagne qu'on a déployé depuis
cette année sur le justement sur
l'antibiothérapie sous la forme de Data
visualisation et qui permettra dans les
prochains mois les prochaines années au
médecin à tout moment d'avoir accès à
leur prescription et de pouvoir se
comparer de manière pédagogique et
efficace ça nous semble un outil que les
médecins demandés et qu'ils ont plutôt
très bien
nous déployons d'autres leviers qui sont
plus un peu plus mordants si vous me
permettez l'expression notamment avec
des dispositifs d'accord préalable que
nous avons déployés sur certains
médicaments
ces dernières années pour vérifier que
leur utilisation là aussi respectent
bien les indications remboursables avec
un système de téléservices qui permet
une réponse extrêmement rapide du
service médical aux demandes des
médecins et qui participent de
mécanismes qu'on voit dans d'autres pays
qui soumettent la prescription de
médicaments coûteux notamment à un
accord de l'Assurance Maladie ce qui est
le dernier qui fait le lien avec le
dernier le dernier réaction que nous
déployons vous voyez qu'il y a encore
une fois un continuum information
accompagnement incitation financière à
corps préalable la lutte contre les
trafics de médicaments qui
malheureusement existe dans notre pays
et qui peuvent le cas échéant ce n'est
pas l'explication principale
certainement des pénuries mais qui
peuvent participer malheureusement aussi
d'une mauvaise utilisation bien sûr des
produits de santé nous avons signé avec
les pharmaciens une nouvelle convention
au début de l'année 2022 dans lequel
nous avons engagé avec eux un travail de
vérification systématique des
ordonnances pour des médicaments coûteux
de plus de 300 euros qui se déploient
depuis
le dernier trimestre de l'année 2022 un
peu tôt pour partager le bilan mais nous
sommes malheureusement confrontés de
plus en plus à des à des trafics de
médicaments avec un certain nombre de
procédures pénales qui ont justifié une
action une action renforcée nous
déployons aussi des outils transversaux
numériques avec notamment l'ail
prescription plutôt l'ordonnance
numérique qui permettra de mieux
sécuriser les les prescriptions diminuer
le risque d'utilisation de fausses
ordonnances mais voilà c'est dans le
continuum des actions je pense qu'il est
utile de mentionner ce phénomène
voilà ce que je voulais dire madame la
Présidente sur Madame laboratoire sur le
les actions que nous menons peut-être
deux éléments
de réflexion un peu transversale si je
peux me permettre
pour revenir au sujet plus large des
pénuries d'abord encore une fois vous
redire notre conviction que le prix
n'est pas le seul n'est pas le principal
élément qui justifie qui explique les
difficultés que nous rencontrons ça nous
semble être beaucoup plus compliqué que
ça et la France reste à marcher
attractif pour l'industrie du médicament
et avec un accès rapide
aux molécules innovantes nous l'avons
montré
y compris dans le dernier rapport chargé
produit nous ne pouvons pas
assumer ou construire une politique de
soutenabilité des dépenses d'assurance
maladie si le médicament ne participe
pas comme d'autres champs à ces
politiques déficiences et donc au juste
prix y compris du cycle de vie des
produits santé donc il est normal que
des médicaments
matures subissent des baisses de prix
progressives qui sont à la main du
comité économique des produits santé
mais il y a un équilibre également à
trouver entre l'accès à l'innovation
avec des coûts très élevés et
l'évolution des prix sur le cycle de vie
du produit et puis je voulais partager
avec vous deux éléments un peut-être une
évidence mais tout de même
il me semble que la réponse elle est
aussi très fortement à construire au
niveau européen
nous sommes un très grand marché
d'accès aux produits santé au niveau
européen
la France je crois reste attaché à ce
que ça ça poétique du médicament soit
construite au niveau national mais nous
aurions certainement intérêt à
comment dirais-je
construire des modes de dialogue avec
les industries du médicament des
multinationales en prenant appui sur un
effet de taille qui est le continent
européen j'ai des souvenirs il y a
quelques années de discussion que nous
avions avec nos homologues allemands sur
les médicaments sur les pâtisser où nous
avions essayé d'avoir des approches
communes c'est extrêmement compliqué
mais France plus Allemagne égale 140
millions de patients et donc c'est des
marchés considérables et puis un peu
dans le même ordre d'idée partagez avec
l'idée que ne serait-ce qu'à l'échelle
de la France nous sommes un financeur et
un acheteur de pas loin de 30 milliards
de dépenses de produits de santé
un acheteur qui achète ce niveau de
volume et de dépense devrait pouvoir
avoir de la part de ses fournisseurs des
garanties supplémentaires
des garanties supplémentaires sur les
conditions de continuité de
l'approvisionnement
envers ses clients pardon le dire comme
ça un très grand industriels ont des
garanties vis-à-vis de leur fournisseurs
sur le fait que les
matières premières ou les pièces dont
ils ont besoin
l'approvisionnement leur égarantie et si
cette approvisionnement n'est pas au
rendez-vous alors des pénalités sont
prononcées je ne dis pas que ce sujet se
résume à faire des pénalités sur les
industriels mais je considère que nous
devrions avoir de la part des
industriels davantage de garantie sur la
continuité de l'approvisionnement des
médicaments dans notre pays au regard du
marché que nous représentons et des
dépenses que nous finançons
c'est un sujet encore une fois majeur
pour l'AS maladie qui a été aux côtés
des assurés et des professionnels de
santé et notamment des pharmaciens dans
la crise récente qu'il y aura permis qui
a accompagné leur mobilisation y compris
sur le financement de
préparation magistrale pour faire face
aux pénuries de médicaments que j'ai
évoqué mais en tous les cas le dialogue
auquel nous sommes extrêmement attachés
avec des industries dans le cadre du
comité économique devrait
comporter davantage de garantie sur la
continuité de l'approvisionnement par
l'industrie du médicament pour garantir
la fourniture des médicaments à nos
assurés voilà madame la présidente
Madame la rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs ce que je voulais partager en
propos introductifs
je vous remercie vous avez déjà apporté
un certain nombre de sujets
j'ai immédiatement passé la parole à
ma collègue Laurence Cohen qui est
rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le directeur
pour compléter donc votre propos
introductif j'aimerais justement pour
mieux prendre en compte les enjeux qui
sont liés à l'approvisionnement du
marché français je voudrais savoir
comment vous appréhendez en fait les
dispositions qui ont été prises par la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale de 2022 et notamment qui a pris
comme critère la fixation des prix parce
que à la fois vous nous dites vous nous
avez dit dans votre propos très
clairement que pour vous ça n'est pas la
fixation enfin le prix qui serait trop
bas parce que c'est vrai qu'on l'a on
l'a beaucoup lu beaucoup entendu qui
serait une des causes de la pénurie des
médicaments donc comment vous
appréhendez cette loi de de financement
ça c'est ma première question
ma deuxième question elle est liée
justement au niveau des produits qui
sont vous avez d'un côté donc les
produits matures qui sont très peu
élevés le prix est très peu élevé puis
l'autre côté vous avez donc les
molécules innovantes qui sont
extrêmement élevés pour pour la plupart
donc est-ce que il n'y a pas là donc un
déséquilibre très important et comment
vous éventuellement au niveau de la
Caisse d'Assurance Maladie vous pouvez
jouer n'est pas le mot mais en tout cas
vous pouvez travailler sur ces sur ces
deux sur ces deux aspects sur ces deux
aspects là ma troisième question c'est
concernant les ruptures de stock vous
l'avez un petit peu évoqué sur les
ruptures de stock et donc les
difficultés d'approvisionnement des
médicaments mais quand les choses sont
avérées il y a de la part des médecins
une adaptation qui est absolument
obligatoire et du coup qui qui prévoit
des alternative thérapeutique et ces
alternatives thérapeutiques peuvent être
ou pas mais plus plus onéreuses donc
est-ce que vous avez là vous au niveau
de la CPAM une évaluation donc de
ce coup des ruptures des ruptures de
stock l'autre question qui est qui est
lié on l'a déjà posé lors d'audition de
différentes
autres structures c'est concernant sur
les incidences les incidences médicales
qui peuvent être multiples et qui
concernent donc ces pénuries on a vu
donc de la part des patients une une
observance moins assidue on va dire des
traitements il va y avoir des
substitutions de traitement et parfois
il va y avoir y compris des retards de
de prise de traitement donc nous avons
posé la question à plusieurs reprises
pour savoir
est-ce que on est en capacité
aujourd'hui de mesurer donc ces
incidences en termes en termes de de
coût et ma dernière ma dernière question
vous dites juste titre ce que nous
pouvons partager il y a une réponse à
construire au niveau au niveau européen
mais effectivement cette cette réponse a
construire au niveau européen ne peut
pas constituer une excuse pour ne pas en
construire au niveau au niveau national
donc justement comment s'articule ces
réponses de votre point de vue c'est à
dire que il faut pas que on s'attend de
mutuellement en gros pour le dire de
manière beaucoup plus directe et plus
familière c'est à dire que la France
peut aussi servir d'exemple à un moment
donné sur les réponses ou les
propositions de réponses qu'elles peut
apporter continue de son histoire et
de l'expérience qu'elle peut qu'elle
peut avoir en la matière donc voilà les
questions qui me viennent à l'esprit à
partir de votre propos liminaire
alors
c'est d'apporter un certain nombre de
réponses
la loi de financement pour 2022
notamment son article 65 et
je crois qu'il doit se lire dans un dans
un lien avec l'accord cadre qui a été
qui a évolué peu de temps auparavant et
dans le cadre des engagements que qui
ont été pris dans le cadre du du 6 elle
vise à essayer de concilier finalement
différents objectifs à la fois
d'attractivité du territoire de
localisation
sur le territoire national de de
production de médicaments avec des
objectifs de régulation et de
soutenabilité et donc de faire évoluer
les conditions notamment de fixation du
prix
pour intégrer plus peut-être plus
clairement plus efficacement d'autres
critères et notamment en lien avec on va
dire comme on dit parfois une empreinte
industrielle de ce point de vue là
nous sommes partis prenantes de cette
politique publique en tant que membre du
comité économique qui ensuite à qui
revient la responsabilité de mettre en
musique ce cadre législatif
pour éviter tout ambiguïté et même si
quelque part ça n'est pas notre
compétence prioritaire on est
extrêmement conscient de l'importance de
cet équilibre entre les différentes
composantes de la politique du
médicament souveraineté
attractivité innovation régulation tous
ces objectifs doivent se concilier moi
je considère que le comité économique
est un objet précieux en ce qu'ils
justement et le comité qui réunit
l'ensemble des acteurs de l'état de
l'assurance maladie des organismes
complémentaires dans leurs différentes
composantes et qui quelque part qui
revient une difficile mission de faire
synthèse de ses objectifs là sur la base
d'un cadre qui est voté par le Parlement
proposé par le gouvernement et qui
a fait évoluer les entre guillemets les
règles du jeu si je reprends votre terme
sur voilà ces différents critères donc
après les choses sont encore récentes
pour apprécier les conditions dans
lesquelles ces différents dispositions
évoluent je pense quand même que la
comment dirais-je le poids pris par ces
sujets
d'attractivité d'investissement en
France ont bien identifiés par
l'ensemble des membres du comité et que
dans les différentes négociations
menées depuis quelques mois tout le
monde a bien ce sujet là en tête donc je
crois que les choses sont clairement
appréhendées même si on n'a pas encore
tout le tout le recul nécessaire ça fait
le lien avec le si je peux me permettre
avec votre deuxième question comment
quelque part se fait l'équilibre si j'ai
bien compris cette question entre une
politique de prix plutôt autour de
l'innovation et une politique de prix
plutôt autour de produits plus mature
c'est là aussi c'est toute l'attention
qui s'exerce sur
la soutenabilité des dépenses de
produits santé
au sein du comité économique nous sommes
extrêmement attachés à ce que les
innovations
bénéficient de prix d'ailleurs dans une
fois dans un cadre qui est largement
fixé par la gorcade et le cas de
législatif qui valorise cette innovation
après nous sommes préoccupés en même
temps par des niveaux de prix qui sont
parfois demandés par les industriels à
des niveaux extrêmement élevés et que
[Musique]
si nous sommes dans une logique avec à
la fois des prix
faciaux élevés des prix net qui doivent
être pas trop bas parce que pas trop de
remise et des une clause de sauvegarde
qui ne doit pas être trop élevée parce
que si elle est trop élevée elle finit
par être insupportable et que en même
temps on a des prix très élevés en
demande sur l'innovation et des prix sur
les produits climatures qui ne peuvent
pas évoluer à un moment donné le sujet
de la soutenabilité se pose et que les
dépenses de médicaments de ville en 2022
ont progressé de 8 et demi pour cent
huit et demi pour cent ce qui est
considérable et qui à un moment donné on
doit faire le lien entre
des financements de l'assurance maladie
qui
vont plus vite que
[Musique]
évidemment des politiques que nous
menons
sur les deux autres questions que vous
posez sur je crois l'évaluation de de de
l'impact des ruptures de stock à la fois
financièrement sur le recours à des
alternatives thérapeutiques plus
coûteuses et compris sur les incidences
de santé publique je crains
malheureusement ne pas avoir de réponse
extrêmement étayé à vous fournir
j'aurais envie de vous dire et compris
dans la crise récente que
dès lors que les pénuries exposent nos
assurés à des à des risques de de défaut
de prise en charge ça n'est certainement
pas le critère financier qui vient en
première ligne de compte pour dire les
choses encore plus directement nous
avons financé et franchement il fallait
le faire des comment dire des
préparations magistrales par les
pharmaciens à des niveaux nettement plus
élevés que les médicaments qui étaient
en rupture et honnêtement heureusement
qu'on l'a fait ils ont pas posé la
question 5 minutes de dire c'est trop
cher on le fera pas d'ailleurs je
contrôle demain les prises étaient
relativement sans cadre
bien bien établi donc voilà le sujet
avant tout c'est de garantir et de se
mobiliser
d'accompagner la mobilisation des
professionnels pour répondre aux besoins
des patients c'est dans ces cadres là
que la question de la régulation
budgétaire je dirais ne pas vocation à
se poser pour faire face à des
situations d'urgence
et s'agissant des incidences en termes
de santé publique alors j'aurais presque
tendance à vous dire que
même si ça fait partie des trois
priorités que j'ai évoqué c'est des
choses qui nécessiteraient des travaux
plus approfondis avec nos parts nos
partenaires soit de la NSM sur
l'autorité soit ni misère de la santé
mais à ma connaissance en tout cas j'ai
pas eu connaissance de travaux engagés
sur ces sujets-là en tout cas dans la
période récente
dernier volet sur je dirais le National
et l'Européen si je ou les enjeux
européens il est bien évident c'est pour
ça que je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure que
la
le déploiement d'une feuille de route
nationale de lutte contre les pénuries
et quelque part
aussi de de d'attractivité de notre pays
on y est pleinement attaché et on en est
on souhaite en être un des un des
moteurs même si pas mal de choses ne
relèvent pas de l'Assurance Maladie
voilà maintenant je pense que c'est bien
à ces deux niveaux là que les choses se
jouent on l'a vu pendant la crise covid
et un moment donné ça n'est pas une
proposition que je fais mais c'est bien
au niveau européen que c'est monnaie la
négociation des vaccins et à un moment
donné nous européen représentons un
marché très substantiel et je pense que
vis-à-vis des industries qui sont des
industries multinationales je pense que
nous gagnerions à davantage nous appuyer
sur cette dimension européenne cette
dimension de taille de marché pour
quelque part avoir un dialogue plus
équilibré et nous mettre à l'abri de
situations de rupture dans
dans les pays européens
concernés ça nous semble être voilà je
crois pas que vous le fassiez mais je ne
pose pas les deux dy namiques et que ce
soit sur la liste des médicaments
d'intérêt stratégiques en termes
industriel et sanitaire que ce soit sur
la gestion des la prévention des
ruptures la cartographie le suivi il est
bien évident qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses à
approfondir au niveau national sans
renvoyer entre guillemets le BTB au
niveau européen
très bien merci beaucoup moi quelques
questions complémentaires et je vais
passer la parole à mes collègues qui
prennent leur tour
juste pour revenir sur cette application
de prix bas pour les médicaments matures
manifestement le prix n'est pas à
proportionnel au service médical rendu
en tout cas pas toujours et pour les
inhibiteurs de la pompe à protons par
exemple enfin on nous a témoigné d'une
baisse cette fois du du montant de
l'oméprazole sur une quinzaine d'années
à peu près parce que c'est un médicament
qui est pas très ancien mais qui pour le
coup pas tant que ça c'est pas se fait
pas partie des médicaments qu'on 50 ans
en tout cas ils ont été une vraie
révolution quand ils sont arrivés sur le
marché et le service médical rendu ce
calcul également en euros selon les
trébuchants puisque c'est un certain
nombre de pathologies qu'on est plus
obligé de prendre en charge à l'hôpital
et même si certes c'est pas la même
ligne budgétaire le médicament et
l'hôpital il y a quand même du point de
vue de l'Assurance Maladie voilà une
logique financière de bonne gestion
donc finalement ce prix
donc vous vous évoquez le fait que ça
fait partie des éléments mais que en
aucun cas c'est un élément
fondateur des problématiques où il nous
faisons face en même temps dans les
propositions gouvernementales il y a un
moratoire sur la sur les baisses de prix
qui vient d'être proposées ça veut dire
quand même que même s'il y a pas un lien
immédiat il existe quand même un petit
peu
et donc en fait moi j'aimerais
comprendre parce que cette question du
prix reste quand même un vrai sujet quoi
qu'on en dise puisque ça crée des
concurrences frontières et
les habitants de l'Est ou du Nord de la
France le savent bien ils trouvent
certains médicaments de l'autre côté de
la frontière qui ne trouvent pas qui ne
trouve pas en France par exemple
et moi j'aimerais comprendre
comment
cette baisse de prix se décide
c'est-à-dire sur un plan qualitatif
parce que il y a un service médical
rendu donc il y a un bénéfice en matière
de dépose de dépenses de santé publique
et en matière de dépenses de l'assurance
maladie et est-ce que ce bénéfice est
pris en compte dans la baisse de prix en
d'autres termes si le bénéfice reste
quand même très important
est-ce que quelque part
on n'est pas attentif à maintenir un
prix suffisant de façon à ce qu'on soit
pas face à des pénuries puisque quand
même les pénuries récentes sont quand
même des périodes nourries sur des
médicaments
essentiels ça c'est ma première question
ma deuxième question
donc vous avez écouté la question des
bonnes pratiques sur le paracétamol par
exemple le paracétamol est en vente
libre et donc comment comment on gère
cette question de la vente libre et de
la pénurie parce que même si
même s'il est prescripteur prescrivent
moins au mieux
voilà dans l'accompagnement il ne rentre
pas moins que la vente libre et
forcément source de de pénurie
et donc et ma dernière question porte
sur sur le comité d'évaluation parce que
effectivement on a bien compris que
c'était une relation
contractuelle avec avec l'élaboratoires
que vous participiez à cette discussion
et vous avez déploré le manque de
garantie qu'on déplore tous sur les
questions de pénurie d'alerte voilà
d'anticipation on peut dire les choses
de cette façon en tout cas et quel
comment vous souhaiteriez voir les
choses évoluer vous avez parlé de
contraintes supplémentaires de voilà
donc avoir votre point de vue sur ce
sujet et puis ma dernière question c'est
comment vous estimez à combien vous
estimez le coût
le coup des de substitution
en l'état actuel des choses parce que
Philippe pénurie dit coût de
substitution y compris dans la dépense
hospitalière puisque parfois c'est hors
appel d'offres qu'on est obligé de se
fournir y compris sur d'autres
laboratoires à un prix nettement plus
cher sur un certain nombre de
médicaments et ça ça rentre dans les
dépenses évidemment de l'Assurance
Maladie enfin en tout cas dans les
arbitrages budgétaires compliqués à
gérer donc ce coup-là qui a un coût réel
est-ce que ben voilà peut-être mieux
adapter le prix du médicament
pourrait diminuer ce coup de de la
substitution
et je suis passé la parole donc à ma
collègue Laurence harribé et Pascal
grenier ensuite
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur général
c'est votre propos était fort
intéressant pour nous éclairer sur le
processus et le rôle de la CNAM moi je
retiens dans ce que vous avez dit vous
avez parlé de fixation des prix du
médicament même si on est à l'intérieur
d'un corridor largement déterminé j'ai
retenu ça et ensuite dans les priorités
la question de la soutenabilité avec une
logique déficience et en fait en
préparant cette audition je me suis un
peu j'ai regardé un petit peu dans mes
notes et dans les dans les un certain
nombre de d'affaires
anciennes et notamment je suis revenu
sur l'histoire de du conflit entre la
CNAM et Sanofi à propos du du plat Vicks
pour les maladies cardiovasculaires et
j'ai l'impression en fait que on a d'un
côté et le propos de la rapporteur et de
la présidente le confirme que on a toute
la question autour des médicaments
matures où on presse le sur ces
médicaments matures aux risques de
désorganiser toute la branche et toute
la filière industrielle et puis qu'on
favorise l'innovation ce qu'on peut
comprendre aussi sauf qu'il y a un
moment donné il y a des labos et des
industries qui sont un peu sur les deux
et que tout le problème qui se pose
c'est le problème de la transition entre
le
l'innovation et la maturité du du
médicament et cette affaire Sanofi
autour du plavix et est assez
révélatrice mais peut-être que j'y
connais rien et que je mon regard
extérieur est complètement
Tron novice pour être exact donc
j'aimerais bien que vous nous expliquiez
ce qui s'est passé parce que finalement
on se rend compte que la CNAM n'a rien
négocié du tout pendant un temps
important et qu'il a fallu que ce soit
le
tribunal qui reviennent là-dessus et qui
et qui permette à la à la CNAM de
récupérer je crois quelques centaines de
enfin une centaine de millions d'euros
et donc je n'arrive pas à comprendre
finalement parce que
je veux bien que le corridor il soit il
soit étroit mais j'ai l'impression quand
même alors est-ce qu'il manque des
outils est-ce que est-ce que finalement
cette il y a trop d'institutions qui
jouent et qu'il faut clarifier les
choses le rôle de chacun mais en tout
cas cet exemple me semble assez
caractéristique et révélateur de cette
difficulté là alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous éclairer là-dessus pour
enfin en tout cas moi je suis
relativement
je comprends pas tout quoi j'aimerais
bien comprendre
Pascal Boni
la présidente
on a besoin vraiment de réponse nous
sommes dans une commission d'enquête et
pas une mission d'information donc on
veut des réponses très précises très
précises et sur le prix vous avez dit
que en fait on était finalement mieux
placé que que les États-Unis ou tout du
moins c'était pas pire et puis que au
niveau Union européenne tout était à peu
près identique ça n'est pas vrai ou tout
du moins tout ce qu'on lit nous on a
fait des auditions dans le cadre de la
commission des affaires européennes ça
n'est pas vrai la France elle est en
dessous et largement en dessous et ça
fait partie parce que on a auditionné
aussi nos des groupes d'entreprises et
de petits laboratoires petits moyens
laboratoire qui nous ont franchement dit
que le prix en France amené à la pénurie
et que même l'un d'entre eux
choisi en fait de vendre à l'extérieur
de la France ces produits plutôt qu'en
France donc nous on aimerait bien avoir
une réponse je vous rappelle commission
d'enquête donc c'est pas du tout la même
chose et la clause de sauvegarde aussi
qui nous pénalise également et bien
entendu sur la pénurie de médicaments et
sur nos entreprises les stocks aussi on
veut savoir justement comment vous
faites sur sur les médicaments soit on
fait pas de stock soit on n'est pas les
entreprises pour faire les stocks donc
dites nous dites nous vraiment ce qui se
passe en France aujourd'hui pour être
vraiment les derniers de la classe au
sujet de la pénurie des médicaments ce
n'est pas le dernier on est
l'avant-dernier c'est pas grave en tout
cas à côté on fait beaucoup mieux on n'a
pas bien compris aussi la hausse des
8,5% du prix de du médicament donc
comment vous pouvez nous l'expliquer
parce qu'on se pose des questions après
sur les bios similaires les génériques
et les négociations avec les
laboratoires français du médicament on
voit pas très bien ce que vous avez
voulu nous dire et là aussi on veut des
choses vraiment très précises merci
pas d'autres demandes dans l'immédiat
Monsieur le Directeur Général j'ai
essayé de ça fait déjà beaucoup
[Musique]
d'abord peut-être préciser ce que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure je ne dis pas que
le prix ne compte en rien dans le débat
sur la sur la pénurie je dis juste que
ça ne peut pas être la seule et unique
explication
aux pénuries que nous connaissons j'ai
pris deux exemples pour bien préciser
les États-Unis sont de loin le pays où
les prix du médicament sont les plus
élevés
je vous rejoins madame sénatrice il y a
pas photo on a des prix plus bas que les
Américains pourquoi parce que c'est sur
les marchés américains que l'industrie
fait d'abord sa rentabilité qu'ensuite
il vient sur les autres marchés dans
lequel du coup les prix sont plus bas
mais je dis que l'exemple typique et aux
États-Unis ils connaissaient également
des pénuries parce que c'est pénuries
répondent à des logiques de problèmes de
matières premières de problèmes de
production industrie de problèmes de
quand la Chine est l'un dans des
problèmes quand ils ont des des
surconsommation voilà et que c'est un
phénomène par de manière comme ça
planétaire et donc on veut pas dire
c'est parce que la France a des prix
plus bas que les autres pays qu'on a un
problème massif de pénurie je crois pas
que ça soit la principale réponse après
c'est pas une information c'est une
c'est une analyse que je porte parce que
ce phénomène il est multifactoriel et je
prends un exemple très clair là aussi
civile la motricilline le prix en France
il est deux fois plus élevé qu'en
Espagne et qu'au Royaume-Uni
deux fois plus élevé en UCD
alors que nous avons connu des pénuries
le prix de la monoxycine en 5 ans il a
augmenté de 9% dans notre pays
et nous connaissons des pénuries donc je
donc je pense que les relations ne sont
pas univoques elles sont elles sont
complexes c'est un phénomène qui n'est
pas le même selon qu'on parle les
différents types de molécules selon les
périodes selon les pays selon les voilà
je pense que il y a pas une seule vérité
le prix fait partie du débat et c'est la
raison pour laquelle le gouvernement a
décidé à la fois un moratoire et c'est
la raison pour laquelle elle a aussi
décidé une mission
qu'il a confiée à un instant de
personnalités qualifiée sur la
régulation du médicament et sur
l'ensemble de la politique du médicament
qui va notamment traiter de ces sujets
et de l'équilibre entre des enjeux de
souveraineté et de et de soutenabilité
parce que encore une fois c'est des
politiques publiques qui qui faut
concilier quand je prenais le chiffre de
8,5%. c'est l'évolution des dépenses de
médicaments remboursés par l'assurance
maladie sur la ville c'est de simplement
vous repartager le fait que quand vous
avez une dépense
de médicaments d'autres d'ailleurs de
même qui progressent à ce niveau aussi
dynamique alors c'est une certaine façon
une bonne une bonne nouvelle parce que
ça veut dire qu'on a un accès au
traitement facile ça veut dire que
l'innovation se diffuse parce que ça
veut dire que des médicaments coûteux
qui étaient auparavant à l'hôpital se
diffusent en ville etc mais ça pose un
problème de soutenabilité quand vous
avez un nom d'âme qui est selon les
années entre deux trois et quatre pour
cent c'est simplement ce sujet que je
voulais évoquer c'est que
moi je comprends pas bien la les 8,5
c'est sur le prix ou c'est sur la
défense de la ville dedans vous avez le
volume bien
l'ensemble de dépenses remboursées donc
vous aviez dit
aux parents on n'a pas compris la même
chose
j'ai pas été clair c'est bien les
dépenses remboursées de ville ils ont
progressé en 8,5 là dedans il y a des il
y a de la dynamique de volume il y a de
la dynamique de prix il y a une
déformation du médicament qui fait qui
on va de plus en plus dans des
médicaments coûteux parce que et encore
une fois ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
j'ai essayé de partager avec vous
l'ensemble des leviers d'action que nous
mobilisions pour pouvoir
justement garantir que ces volumes là
quelque part sont correspondent
pleinement à des besoins de santé à des
bonnes prises en charge conforme aux
référentiel mais c'est un travail de
extrêmement difficile que de faire
évoluer les prescriptions dans notre
pays dans d'autres d'ailleurs et donc la
politique de bon usage du médicament
c'est à la fois une régulation des prix
et une gestion des
des volumes je reviens juste ensuite sur
le sur la sur la gestion des prix
honnêtement elle se fait selon des
règles du jeu qui visent à la fois à
partir de l'évaluation du médicament
est-ce que quel est le service médical
rendu quelle est l'amélioration du
service médical enduit et puis ensuite
quels sont les comparateurs
quelles sont les comparateurs sur cette
base là que le comité économique encore
une fois dans le cas d'un nom d'un voté
par le Parlement dans le cadre de règles
du jeu fixées par le Parlement et le
pouvoir réglementaire dans le cas d'un
accord cadre qu'il a construit avec
l'industrie du médicament hymène une
politique de gestion des prix à la
hausse ou à la baisse d'ailleurs voilà
je n'ai plus en tête le le l'exemple
très précis des IPP que vous évoquez
mais si c'est pris ont baissé c'est
parce qu'il a été considéré et en lien
d'ailleurs avec les industriels
concernés que
au regard de l'amélioration des services
médicales rendus au regard des
comparateurs qui existaient alors le
prix concerné pouvait baisser et chaque
année depuis
au moins 10 ou 15 ans le comité
économique a un mandat de faire évoluer
les prix pour pouvoir faire que le
médicament contribue avec d'autres
postes de dépenses à au respect de la
dame donc ça c'est quelque chose de
normal
mais il le fait dans un cadre qui est
fixé par encore une fois
les lois de financement successives
l'accord cadre et donc je crois de
manière transparente et je pense
relativement efficace je vous l'ai dit
je pense que c'est un dispositif qui
fonctionne qui fonctionne plutôt bien
s'agissant de vous me demandiez d'aller
plus loin dans ce que j'avais évoqué sur
la garantie je je
pense que les travaux en cours sur à la
fois le plan pénurie du gouvernement et
vos travaux et ceux d'autres d'autres
acteurs qui réfléchissent à ces sujets
devraient davantage intégrer y compris
dans la négociation que nous menons que
le comité a avec
les industriels le fait que lorsqu'on
fixe un prix lorsqu'on donne donc un
accès au marché lorsqu'on rembourse et
bien je pense que nous devrions
réfléchir à des dispositifs qui
permettent d'assurer la continuité de
l'approvisionnement la loi de
financement pour 2020 prévoit un
dispositif de sanctions si l'industriel
ne
comment dirais-je n'assure pas la
continuité d'approvisionnement et s'il
est amené à procéder importations
d'alternative plus coûteuses je pense
que ça fait partie des dispositifs que
nous devons pouvoir utiliser encore une
fois nous sommes un acheteur de
médicaments à des niveaux de volume
extrêmement élevés et comme tout
acheteur nous devrions avoir davantage
de garantie que le fournisseur répond à
ses obligations et garantit à nos
assurés l'accès aux traitement madame
récréatrice j'aimerais bien interroger
sur plavix peut-être juste resituer nous
avons effectivement eu un contentieux
avec
l'assurance maladie est également partie
prenante pour pouvoir faire valoir nos
droits nous avons d'ailleurs obtenu gain
de cause en tout cas dans l'état actuel
du dossier puisque la dernière décision
juridictionnelle récente nous donne gain
de cause il y a des travaux qui sont
encore en cours en termes de d'expertise
pour déterminer le préjudice
préciser précis dont a été victime de
l'assurance maladie mais donc je
considère qu'on a été de ce point de vue
là actif pour faire valoir nos droits et
pour
et pour voilà nous sommes quand même
parti prenante à la procédure donc je
pense que l'assurance maladie a fait
valoir a fait valoir ses droits
vous dites que vous négociez vous avez
en charge à négociation donc moi la
question que je me pose c'est de savoir
pourquoi il a fallu attendre 7 ans pour
s'interroger sur sur ce sur ce cas et
finalement oui vous vous en êtes la CNAM
s'en est bien sorti mais pourquoi avoir
attendu si longtemps pour lancer la
procédure et que même le premier
jugement aboutissait à une prescription
et que après on a considéré que non la
CNAM était en droit de demander des des
dommagements on pourra vous apporter des
éléments précis sur le détail de la
procédure je je
crois qu'on a encore une fois été actif
pour défendre nos droits et par rapport
à des pratiques que d'ailleurs la
justice a considéré comme étant comme
étant répréhensible en notre défaveur en
tout cas nous sommes extrêmement
attentifs à voilà
à tenter les procédures si elles sont
justifiées dès lors que nous faisons
face à des à des problématiques comme
seules du platvix madame est sénatrice
je crois que j'ai pardon j'ai fait c'est
un peu dans le désordre mais essayer
d'apporter un certain nombre d'éléments
précis il est vrai que sur un certain
nombre d'éléments à ce stade nous ne
bénéficions pas de n'avons pas toutes
les réponses je l'ai dit sur
l'évaluation
économique ou sanitaire des pénuries
c'est sans doute des domaines dans
lequel nous devons continuer à
travailler même si nous n'aurons pas
forcément toutes les sources
d'informations pour réaliser ce type de
travaux qui sont sans doute relativement
complexes
il veut aussi la clause de sauvegarde
mais la clause de sauvegarde enfin en
tout cas d'abord c'est un dispositif qui
n'est pas géré par l'assurance maladie
c'est un dispositif que j'irai par le
pouvoir réglementaire sur la base d'un
dispositif voté par le Parlement elle
participe de d'un équilibre entre
trois niveaux de discussion sur la
fixation du prix le niveau du prix
faciale le niveau du prix net et le
niveau de la clause de sauvegarde
quel est l'équilibre entre ces trois
leviers pour participer de la sodilité
les industriels nous disent et on peut
les comprendre si vous tapez trop fort
sur le prix facial alors on a un sujet
de compétitivité vis-à-vis des autres
pays si vous tapez trop fort sur le sur
les remises produits alors en réalité
vous faites vous faites trop
peser la pression sur les
industries les plus innovantes puisque
c'est elle qui vont payer plus de remise
et si vous faites trop sur la clause
sauvegarde alors c'est une forme d'impôt
transversal sur l'ensemble de
l'industrie et ça c'est pas acceptable
donc je pense que la question du bon
équilibre entre ces différents outils
est un sujet compliqué
et qui est relié après à au choix qui
sont faits par le Parlement je le dis
bien aussi qui décide d'un objectif de
dépenses d'assurance maladie chaque
année et donc d'une soutenabilité de ses
dépenses et donc de choix de régulation
qui s'appliquent aux médicaments comme
un autre domaine
merci beaucoup donc dernière salle de
question
Laurence murboone et Bruno Bolla ensuite
madame la rapporteur
reprendra quelques questions et moi
également
merci madame la Présidente
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur pour toutes les informations
que vous venez de nous présenter alors
j'avais des questions qui peuvent
paraître très simples parce que je suis
pas du tout de la profession mais vous
parliez donc que vous êtes acheteur de
médicaments une idée de votre budget
pour acheter ces médicaments j'en ai
aucune idée j'imagine c'était un budget
important et vous disiez tout à l'heure
que vous fixiez les taux de
remboursement de ces médicaments vous
aviez peu de marge de manœuvre alors
quels sont comment comment décidez-vous
de du remboursement des différents taux
que vous allez appliquer sur les
médicaments et est-ce que c'est aussi
vous qui décidez du non remboursement de
médicaments là je pense notamment encore
une fois à l'homéopathie qui a été
déremboursée est-ce que c'est vous avez
quelque chose à préciser dans ces
décisions là et encore une fois vous
avez ouvert votre propos sur l'Europe
tout à l'heure en
exprimant l'idée que
les marchés que les marchés de
médicaments
pourraient être négociés au niveau
européen plutôt qu'au niveau national
vous l'avez évoqué d'une façon plutôt
positive moi j'observe ce qui s'est
passé la pendant la crise sanitaire et
tout ce que nous entendons aujourd'hui
sur la négociation européenne des
vaccins contre la covid alors pas de
transparence
des les états n'étaient pas souverains
dans les commandes vous avez vu tout le
scandale qui est en train de se
construire au tout autour de cette
commande donc c'est un exemple qui est
pas tellement convaincant pour laisser
la main à l'Europe sur la commande de
médicaments là ce que vous pouvez nous
dire à ce propos merci
Bruno Belin
merci madame le Président bonjour
monsieur le directeur Bruno Belin
sénateur de la Vienne en CDD et
pharmacien d'officine depuis 32 ans dans
un territoire à 20 habitants km². je
reviendrai sur ce point-là qui était
essentiel alors moi je suis très surpris
votre remarque sur l'amoxicilline
j'étais ce matin dans mon officine et
je ne crois pas je suis même certain que
le prix n'a pas augmenté
alors je ça aurait été prétentieux de ma
part de donner les chiffres de mémoire
mais j'ai regardé en tapant tout
simplement sur un moteur de recherche
connu évolution prix amoxicilline je
vous cite ce que me donne le premier
référent depuis le 1er janvier 2010 le
prix de vente publique
du flacon d'amoxicilline 500 buvable est
passé de 2 47 à 1,87 euros soit une
diminution de 32,1%
et qui soit moins de 2 euros je vous le
confirme c'était le cours du marché ce
matin donc quand vous me dites qu'il est
moins cher en Espagne
voilà il y a une vraie question sur les
prix la prison de Grenier a raison de
d'insister sur le fait nous sommes
devant une commission d'enquête
parlementaire face à un problème d'accès
à la santé grave dont la question du
prix midi médicaments et bien évidemment
une des causes
donc ça moi je tiens à ce que durant
cette mission les choses soient durant
cette commission des choses soient très
claires sur cette évolution on pourrait
prendre d'autres exemples c'est vous qui
avez pris celui-là mais je pourrais en
prendre d'autres ce qu'il faut qu'on
comprenne je rabâche sur le sujet mais
je le ferai parce que c'est un enjeu
territoire de proximité et donc ça
touche des personnes à faible mobilité
quand on touche auprès du médicament
pardon d'attendre votre attention quand
on touche au prix du médicament vous
savez très bien aussi parce que vous
connaissez le système et beaucoup de mes
collègues le connaissent aussi on touche
au financement de la répartition la
répartition c'est ce qui permet qu'une
boîte de arrive dans une caisse de
n'importe où parce qu'il y a une
obligation de service public quasiment
des répartiteurs qui doivent livrer
n'importe quel officine dans les 72
heures et à un moment donné ils ne
peuvent plus face au prix du gazole face
au prix règle de mobilité et tout ce
qu'on leur impose donc bien évidemment
c'est au détriment des officines les
plus rurales et donc au détriment des
populations les plus isolées les plus
rurales
donc le prix du médicament est une des
causes de la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui personne ne sait
ce dont il consomme vous faites un
micro-trottoir devant n'importe quel
officine aujourd'hui de France vous leur
demandez pour combien
le patient part sort de son officine
est-ce qu'il a dans son sac personne ne
sait en tout cas
l'amoxicilline et la question de la
présence grenier est essentielle
l'amoxicilline n'a pas augmenté
contrairement à ce que vous dites ou
alors on n'a pas les mêmes références
merci beaucoup
on
a encore question
oui je trouve que les questions qui ont
qui ont été posées depuis le début son
sont très précises et très pertinentes
et que vous le voyez bien on a on a
besoin d'avoir des réponses tout aussi
tout aussi pointues en fait
et notamment et notamment sur sur les
prix moi je voudrais
élargir un petit peu le propos y compris
en ce que un moment donné vous avez
parlé au niveau des des priorités du
rôle que vous aviez etc vous avez vous
avez parlé aussi de pénalité que vous
pouviez
c'est pas que vous pouviez infliger mais
bon ça allait pénalité c'est pas vous
c'est ce sont ces législatifs etc etc
mais justement par rapport à ces
pénalités est-ce que vous pensez quels
sont suffisantes
qu'elles peuvent être contraignantes
suffisamment contraignantes parce que le
sentiment aussi que que nous pouvons
avoir à l'orée de ces auditions c'est
que si je fais référence par exemple à
ce que nous a dit l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament
elles sont elles sont peu nombreuses et
ce qui est
recueilli et très peu par rapport
à ce qui pourrait l'être donc est-ce que
vous je vous je vous demande pas en fait
je sais bien que les c'est pas à l'acpam
de
déterminer qu'elles doivent être ou non
les pénalités etc mais vous à la
responsabilité qui est la vôtre parce
que on n'est pas seulement là au niveau
de de notre commission d'enquête à faire
un état des lieux c'est très très
important que nous partageions le même
état des lieux ça c'est évident mais ce
qu'on aimerait à la sortie de notre
commission d'enquête pour qu'elle soit
efficace et puis qu'elle soit utile
c'est d'avoir un certain nombre de
propositions pour nourrir le débat et
pour sortir de de cette situation donc
si on a des réponses un peu comment
policier pour nous dire oui voilà c'est
ça on recueille les pénalités on fait si
on fait ça à la limite ça ce sont les
responsabilités de chaque de chaque
institution mais est-ce que vous à la
place qui est la vôtre vous voulez
penser
utile suffisantes ou qu'elles peuvent
être les réponses alternatives qui
pourraient en tant que caisse de
sécurité sociale vous aider et du fait
nous aider parce que c'est ça le souci
on est un peu dans la dans le même
bateau si je puis à m'exprimer ainsi
donc ça la première question et une
question qui est plus on va dire
subsidiaire je voudrais bien comprendre
quand vous dites que pour aider les
professionnels en quelque sorte vous
pouvez leur mettre à disposition
une espèce de protocole en fait sur
j'aimerais avoir un certain nombre de
précisions de précision là-dessus parce
que
là on touche aussi à la liberté de
prescrire etc etc donc comment est-ce
que ça ça
s'intègre et comment réagissent les
professionnels face à ces conseils
que je ne doute pas bienveillant
donc moi je termine parce que vous
n'avez pas répondu à une de mes
questions qui était l'estimation du coût
de la substitution du coup des pénuries
de médicaments finalement au coût de la
supplicitation ou de la fabrication
alternative ça de la production en
officine puisque vous avez dit que ça
enchaîne c'est le coup ou par des
pharmacies
centrales et puis aussi les pénuries
hospitalières où on voit bien que du
coup l'appel d'offres tombe de faite et
on est obligé de de commander un coup
nettement plus cher
auprès d'un autre laboratoire
et ma deuxième question porte sur le
8,5% décidément qui a un chiffre qui
nous a quand même beaucoup interrogé
donc c'est l'évolution des dépenses de
médecine donc c'est le volume sur la
ville
et moi ce que j'aimerais savoir d'abord
c'est quel comment ça s'est passé sur la
partie hospitalière c'est-à-dire le
pendant de la ville du coup du
médicament sur la partie hospitalière et
dans ces 8 et demi pour cent quelle est
la part finalement
liée aux médicaments innovants ou aux
nouvelles prises en charge parce que la
population vieillissant les diagnostics
et les thérapeutiques étant meilleure
qualité on traite les gens plus
longtemps et on en traite un plus grand
nombre et donc quelle est la part de
l'efficience du soin et la part de la
soutenabilité dans les choix qui sont
faits je vous remercie
volume du montant d'achat de médicaments
que nous nous
réalisons ces oses dire je pense que
vous l'avez bien mesuré le terme d'achat
est un peu impropre visa illustrer la
relation entre un fournisseur et des
produits c'est 32 milliards d'euros si
on regarde l'évolution des dépenses
remboursées de médicaments bruts global
c'est 32 milliards d'euros c'est la
raison pour laquelle je permettais de
pousser un peu le raisonnement en disant
que quand on achète entre guillemets 32
milliards d'euros
on peut essayer de poser un certain
nombre de garanties sur le remboursement
sénatrice
quand je disais que nous étions en
compétence lié c'est que le taux de
remboursement des dépend de l'évaluation
de l'efficacité du médicament et selon
les différents niveaux d'évaluation
correspond un taux donc voilà et pour
répondre à votre dernière question dès
lors que la Haute Autorité de Santé dit
ce médicament a un service médical rendu
insuffisant alors il sort du
remboursement
nous ne sommes pas de ce point de vue là
nous sommes en fait en réalité plus un
notaire entre guillemets ou nous nous
tirons les conséquences d'évaluation
sanitaire et c'est heureux séparation
entre celui qui évalue et celui qui paye
c'est une des forces de notre système en
France il faut pas mélanger les
casquettes à la Haute Autorité de dire
ce médicament il est très utile il a un
taux de remboursement élevé je résume un
peu mais ce médicament il est inutile et
justifie pas un remboursement après on
peut débattre je rentre pas dans la
discussion miopathie mais tu es
considéré que c'est comme ça que ça
marche et donc voilà ce point de vue là
nous sommes c'est nous qui exerçons la
compétence de fixer le taux mais arrêtez
c'est une compétence qui est directement
à une appréciation de l'apport médical
le sénateur sur sur les questions que
vous avez évoquées d'abord je je
j'adresserai très rapidement les
éléments sur l'amoxicilline en ma
possession
les prix que j'ai évoqué sont pardon de
rentrer un peu dans l'état mais sont en
unité commune de dispensation en UCD
donc qui traduisent aussi différentes
formes d'utilisation du produit qui qui
peuvent comment dirais-je varier et être
cohérente même si les banques que vous
prenez est évidemment tout à fait
pertinents je ne conteste absolument pas
après les prix moyens hors taxes du nucd
d'amoxicilline au dernier trimestre 2022
sont à 0,17 euros en Allemagne c'est la
même chose en Espagne c'est 0,08 au
Royaume-Uni c'est 0,10
voilà et donc je tiens j'adresserai à la
commission d'enquête ces éléments pour
essayer de comprendre pourquoi il y a
des il y a des écarts et
pour suivre les chances si vous le
souhaitez
pour répondre à votre et alors pour
répondre à votre autre
élément sur l'impact des baisses de prix
sur sur le réseau de distribution c'est
très clairement alors un sujet majeur
pour l'assurance maladie qui a justifié
je pense que vous le savez que depuis
une dizaine d'années nous avons avec les
représentants des pharmaciens fait
évoluer et en lien bien sûr avec le
ministère les le mode de rémunération
des des pharmacies d'officine qui
aujourd'hui est moins dépendant des prix
du médicament qu'il ne l'était il y a 15
ans puisque les différentes
rémunérations différents honoraires qui
se sont ajoutés et les différentes
missions de santé publique qui ont été
reconnues et valorisées par l'Assurance
Maladie participe de cette forme de
désensibilisation partielle partielle du
réseau de distribution pas encore
présente les officines par rapport aux
baisses du médicament donc quand il y a
10 ans on comité économique baissé les
prix de X l'impact sur le l'officier
n'était beaucoup plus élevé
qu'aujourd'hui au dernier congrès pardon
je me fais pas publicité mais de l'un
des deux syndicats de pharmacie et une
étude qui a été diffusée qui n'est pas
notre être sur l'historique de cette la
composition du prix de la des modes de
rémunération des pharmaciens qui m'ont
très très bien ce phénomène de
désensibilisation on pourra tout à fait
vous adresser ces différents éléments et
c'est un sujet pour nous assurance
maladie parce qu'on est extrêmement
attaché
aux partenariat avec les pharmaciens et
surtout à la à la à la solidité du
réseau
officinale pour évidemment assumer ses
missions vis-à-vis des assurés c'est une
politique publique que nous avons
conduit avec le ministère depuis plus
d'une dizaine d'années pour voilà
essayer de faire que les évolutions de
prix pèsent moins sur l'équilibre
économique des pharmacies qui a 10 ou 15
ans et encore une fois les les
évolutions qui ont été partagés montrent
bien ce phénomène de désensibilisation
sur le coût de la de la de la pénurie je
le pardonne dans l'espèce je sais pas si
ça n'est pas une réponse flou ou une
absence nous ne disposions pas
aujourd'hui l'assurance maladie n'a pas
mené de travaux qui évaluent l'impact de
ces pénuries sur
sur les dépenses honnêtement je pense
que ce sera
c'est pas un phénomène tout à fait
récent oui oui tout à fait mais il ne
reste pas moins que c'est un phénomène
relativement complexe à parce qu'il
faudrait quand même regarder qu'est-ce
qui se passe dans ces cas là c'est à
dire que fait le patient est-ce qu'il
prend un autre produit est-ce qu'il
prend rien est-ce qu'il y a un retard
etc donc je me réfugie pas derrière la
complexité mais je pense que ça l'est
vraiment mais nous n'avons pas mené
ce type de
de travaux
et du coup je pense pardon madame la
Présidente vous aviez une dernière
question que j'ai dû ah oui le 8e 8%
c'est là où je sais pas si on a le
chiffre hospitalier ou si vous
allez la rétrocession c'est ça
c'est celui qui allez-y on peut
dans les données effectivement
l'augmentation des dépenses sur les sur
les officines c'est 8,7% pour être très
précis et effectivement les dépenses de
rétrocession elle en revanche sont en
baisse de 5,8% donc la rétrocession
c'est l'accès à l'hôpital à des
médicaments pour la ville les dépenses
de médicaments
lors des séjours on n'a pas la donnée
puisqu'elles sont comprises dans le coup
du GHS donc en fait là il faut remonter
à la fois la comptabilité analytique des
établissements pour aller regarder la
dépense de médicaments dans la
composition du coup du séjour et ça je
vous avoue que c'est une étude qu'on a
pas il serait sûrement d'ailleurs
intéressant qu'on travaille avec la TIH
voilà sur ces sujets là plus
régulièrement mais en tout cas on n'a
pas d'études récentes sur l'évolution du
poids du médicament dans le total de la
formation de la dépense du séjour et
après on a les données sur la distance
Suisse évidemment alors je sais pas si
je les ai là sur les yeux en termes en
termes d'évolution je crois pas mais on
pourra vous les donner en revanche sur
la liste en Suisse qui a remboursé
indépendamment du coût du séjour aux
établissements qui sont en général les
médicaments les plus coûteux ou qui sont
les moins stables dans la formation du
coup du séjour ça en revanche on a la
donnée on pourra vous la communiquer
c'est évidemment des dépenses qui
évoluent assez rapidement ce qu'on a
aussi beaucoup de d'innovation dans ce
choix
très bien merci beaucoup parce que
très sincèrement je
comment dire
je ne crois je ne crois pas que ce soit
par les pénalités qu'on gère le système
je pense que c'est un équilibre général
qui vise à avoir une relation de
confiance encore une fois et dans la
durée un partenariat avec l'industrie du
médicament garantir l'accessibilité au
traitement et que ça fait partie de la
panoplie donc je pense que ça n'est pas
l'alpha et Oméga c'est un outil parmi
d'autres après vous vous m'avez
interrogé sur qu'est-ce qui serait pour
vous le plus important moi je vais dire
les choses clairement le plus important
pour l'assurance maladie c'est d'essayer
de renforcer l'efficacité de nos actions
sur le bon usage des produits santé
pourquoi en France on a 9 millions
d'angines par an et on a un million de
3D
pourquoi pourquoi on prescrit deux fois
plus d'antibiotiques sur les angines que
nécessaire si nous arrivons à être plus
efficace et à faire évoluer les
pratiques des prescripteurs des assurés
qui aujourd'hui ont encore trop s'envoi
en réflexe dire si j'ai une pathologie
alors je dois avoir un médicament un
antibiotique etc ça pour moi c'est pour
ce qui relève en tout cas de mon champ
de responsabilité la chose la plus
importante qui nous mobilise beaucoup
l'assurance maladie on a 800 délégués
d'assurance maladie on a 1200 praticiens
conseils et donc on est extrêmement
mobilisés mais faire changer les
pratiques faire changer les
organisations faire que les patients
vont aller davantage chez le pharmacien
avoir introdangine et pas aller
directement chez le médecin faire que
les médecins m'ont utilisé les trodes
voilà ça c'est pour moi c'est l'acte
c'est en tout cas dans le champ qui est
du champ de responsabilisation asmadies
la réponse la plus importante au pénurie
parce que c'est moins de consommation de
médicaments inut et donc moins de
volumes inutiles et donc un risque de
pénurie plus faible si nous consommions
un niveau de paracétamol alors faire
attention parce que les Allemands ils
consomment moins de parastamol que nous
mais ils consomment beaucoup plus
d'aspiré donc faut faire attention quand
on fait des comparaisons mais si on
consommait des antibiotiques au niveau
des pays européens nous ne nous
n'aurions pas connu de pénurie
d'amoxicilline dans notre pays donc je
dis pas ça pour moto flageller parce que
pour dire que nous sommes pas
suffisamment efficaces mais la réalité
c'est que nous avons du mal à faire
bouger les conditions dans lesquelles
les praticiens et les assurés voient
utilisent le médicament qui est très
hétérogène dans le respect des
référentiels et qui est dans la plupart
des classes thérapeutiques plus élevées
que dans d'autres pays donc il faut pour
essayer de répondre précisément à votre
question c'est pour nous le le principal
sujet que d'être plus efficace sur
l'action sur les volumes
alors il pardon et alors ce que nous ça
dépend des ça dépend vraiment des types
d'opérations ce que nous essayons de
faire généralement c'est de faire deux
choses un si tu es le professionnel de
santé dans sa prescription à lui comment
lui se situe par rapport à ses collègues
ses voisins la même spécialité du
département de du National alors est-ce
qu'il prescrit beaucoup plus
d'antibiotiques beaucoup plus d'ips on
standardise les patients on fait des
choses scientifiquement établies et de
lui rappeler et donc on lui donne ça on
lui donne de la visibilité et puis on
lui donne on diffuse les référentiels
voilà quand est-ce qu'on rappelle que la
Haute Autorité a posé telle ou telle
référentiel que la NSA m'a posé telle
référentiel on rappelle les bonnes les
les guides de bons usages donc c'est
c'est des choses qu'on pourra tout à
fait partager sur les campagnes
paracétamol les campagnes sur la
metformine on s'appuie sur ce qui fait
notre force c'est-à-dire donner aux
professionnels de santé de la visibilité
sur sa prescription et comment il se
situe par rapport à ses collègues et
puis lui diffuser les guides et bonne
pratique sous on essaie de faire des
choses de plus en plus didactiques des
vidéos avec des professionnels de santé
des kits simples de lecture et donc ça
on pourra tout à fait partager avec
votre instance différents exemples qui
montrent ce que nous faisons
est-ce que vous vous avez
constaté en fait une augmentation
justement des antibiotiques avec le fait
de plus avoir d'homéopathe et donc de
plus avoir accès de la même façon aux
médicaments homéopathiques moi je le vis
personnellement où je me soignais à 95%
en homéopathie avec un homoplate
maintenant il y a plus d'homéopathe et
donc je suis sous antibiotique je dirais
-3 fois par an quand même pour
finalement des angines souvent et qui
pourraient peut-être être soigné en
homéopathie et moi je comment je connais
bien un de nos ministres de la Santé
aix-minis de la Santé Xavier Bertrand
qui avait justement lors des réunions
expliquées au médecin que peut-être que
pour eux c'était c'était pas des
médicaments mais qu'en revanche si les
gens se soignaient ça faisait quand même
moins de poids sur justement l'assurance
maladie
alors là je pense que c'est même le
débat de l'usage des financements
d'Assurance Maladie peut-être que déjà
c'est compliqué de rembourser
complètement l'intégralité dans matière
de besoin médicamenteux donc si en plus
on est hors allopathie peut-être la
question se posera on peut peut-être
trouver d'autres moyens de financer en
tout cas on peut toujours y accéder mais
c'est pas remboursé
je reviens sur la question que vous
n'avez pas répondu concernant l'Europe
et l'achat des médicaments au niveau
européen et l'expérience
sur le terrain de pendant la période du
covid et des vaccins qui sont
aujourd'hui en sur commande et qu'on
envoie maintenant des pays africains les
vaccins périmés
alors sur le en tout cas sur les
antibiotiques on n'a pas fait d'études
sur est-ce que il y a un lien que elle
était entre des remboursements de
l'homéopathie et évolution de la dépense
la consommation d'antibiotiques ce que
nous observons en tout cas nous c'est un
recours aux antibiotiques je l'ai évoqué
qu'il reste plus élevé que que chez nos
voisins européens mais qui l'était déjà
si je peux me permettre il était déjà
quand l'homéopathie était remboursé donc
je j'ai encore une fois on n'a pas fait
le travail scientifique mais et donc
notre boulot à nous en l'espèce c'est de
mobiliser différents leviers pour
essayer de diminuer ces prescriptions
inutiles que ce soit les enfants que ce
soit on a des niveaux de prescription
d'antibiotiques qui restent dans notre
pays nettement plus élevé que chez nos
voisins
sur la question que vous posez je
vraiment je considère tout de même que
si chaque pays européen était allé en
mars dispersée voir les différents
industriels du vaccin covid pour
négocier chacun dans son coin des
conditions d'accès au vaccin je crois
que nous aurions eu globalement
alors sans doute que la France parce
qu'elle est un grand pays et un grand
marché ce serait tiré mieux que que
l'Autriche ou malt mais mais je pense
honnêtement la la façon dont ça a été
géré au niveau européen plutôt était un
succès il y a plutôt garanti ce qui
était quand même l'urgence du moment un
accès rapide au vaccin pour les assurer
français et leur j'allais dire leurs
homologues européens en tout cas dans
d'autres pays donc
voilà on se rappelant que l'assurance
maladie n'a fait que financer vaccin n'a
été en aucune manière
encore une fois ce qui était normal
puisque ça a été c'était au niveau de la
Commission européenne un acteur de ces
négociations
de toutes ces réponses
et surtout il y a n'hésitez pas à nous
envoyer tous les éléments
complémentaires et ceux que vous avez
évoqué pendant cette discussion
notamment sur le 8 et demi pour cent qui
ne coupe
interrogé puis la question du de
l'amoxicilline
a dont président d'apporter un
témoignage pour répondre au directeur et
surtout à la question judicieuse de
notre collègue Laurence mirbrone bien
sûr que bien sûr que la substitution
a un coût qui va falloir mesurer qu'en
fin d'année
pardon de prendre un exemple que je j'ai
pratiqué quand vous n'avez plus de bêta
metazone ou de prednisolone qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait on a pris ce qui restait
dans les fonds de tiroirs chez
répartiteur notamment du medrol qui
coûte beaucoup plus cher quand vous
n'avez plus de ces phonoxines des
céphalospoints de troisième génération
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a pris les
deuxièmes puis les premières de
l'alfatile qui coûte beaucoup plus cher
donc au bout du bout
au bout du bout ben oui on a donné de la
fatigue qui coûte plus cher donc au bout
du bout et qui est un précepte qui est
pas un générique c'est évident que ça a
coûté autre marque parce que là je
l'ai trouvé limite blessantes pardon
vous dites si on faisait plus de 3 dans
Jean machin on aurait peut-être moins de
ouais alors
depuis quand les trodes engine
non mais je suis pas énervé vous êtes
énervé vous me verrez ça serait depuis
quand les trottes engine sont-ils
autorisés
ouais
non 1er juillet 2021 1er juillet 2021
pardon de prendre un exemple
professionnel nous avons été sous l'eau
21 22 on était sous l'eau croyez qu'on a
le temps on va faire un test un trottes
de angine pour savoir si le Rocket est
justifié pardon on a été sur le plateau
de 6 heures du matin à 23h donc on s'est
pas préoccupé trop de l'efficience
Testud qui sont sortis le 1er juillet 21
defiscine
deux éléments il est bien clair que
d'abord chez les médecins les trottes se
déployer et beaucoup plus récemment chez
les pharmaciens il n'en reste pas donc
voilà donc ma remarque elle vise
aujourd'hui les pharmaciens et les
médecins elle vit juste à dire que c'est
un outil extrêmement pertinent pour pour
améliorer et diminuer les prescriptions
inutiles d'antibiotiques ça je le
maintiens et
la temporalité n'a pas été la même sur
la mise à disposition des trolls chez
les médecins internationaux mais encore
une fois 9 millions d’angine 9 millions
dans notre pays un million de prod et
voilà et je termine sur le fait que j'ai
à de nombreuses reprises à de nombreuses
reprises monsieur sénateurs soulignés
l'investissement des pharmaciens pendant
la crise covid qu'il s'agisse des tests
et qu'il s'agisse de la je crois qu'on a
été à leur côté pour les accompagner
voilà mais ils ont effectivement été en
première ligne et vous n'avez pas
entendu dire que c'est pas normal que
les pharmaciens n'aient pas fait trop
dans en janvier 22 quand on était en
pleine vague au micro et qu'on essayait
de se débrouiller avec les hôtesses et
les voilà donc on est bien d'accord avec
ça mais il ne reste pas moins que on
consomme encore une fois il y a deux
fois plus deux fois plus d'utilisation
d'antibiothérapie sur les angines que
chez nos voisins
et dans un cas sur neuf on utilise un
trade ça doit quand même nous faire
réfléchir sur l'utilisation des outils
de test débitage qui sont à notre
disposition
je pense que c'est un peu compliqué
d'ouvrir le débat maintenant mais il y a
tous les effets secondaires des angines
non traitées qui pour le coup un coup
largement supplémentaire et une prise en
charge thérapeutique y compris tout au
long de la vie donc voilà tout doit se
comparer dans ces affaires là vous le
savez bien il y a pas il y a pas de il y
a aucun sujet n'est simple et complexe
comme vous le disez tout est complexe
comme vous le dites à juste titre je
vous remercie beaucoup donc n'hésitez
pas donc à nous transmettre les éléments
complémentaires et puis nous enverrons
peut-être une liste de de questions et
je vous remercie beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à ce à ce feu de question merci
à vous